meps condemned a new hungarian law
banning content for children that
promotes homosexuality
we choose freedom we choose equality
they urged the commission and the
council to activate the article 7
process
which could strip hungary of council
voting rights
online child sexual abuse has
dramatically increased during the
pandemic
meps approved legislation to allow
internet services to detect and remove
abusive material
it will apply for three years unless
permanent rules are agreed earlier
parliament adopted the upgraded
connecting europe facility program
which will funnel 30 billion euros into
cross-border transport
energy and digital projects over seven
years
in response to the kovit-19 pandemic
parliament is calling for a strengthened
european medicines agency
that can better monitor medicine
supplies and respond to future health
crises
[Music]
parliament voted on the priorities for
the next environment action program to
2030
meps want to use data technology to
support environmental policy
and to set up a new monitoring mechanism